I feel Danielle's University information
security officer since 1997 and when I
first took the job I thought it was
primarily a
be matching wits against you know
hackers out on the internet and things
like that and then I quickly learned it
involves people and a lot of time it
involve people who would call up and you
know they would say that they thought
somebody else was reading their email
and I would say well why do you think
that and they would say well because my
email is gone or you know somebody's
sending out emails me and I'd say well
do you have an idea who you think it is
and they say oh yeah I think it's my
family member X you know whatever and
I'd say well why do you think it's them
and they say okay I gave them my
password and I'd say well did you change
your password and they'd say yes and I'd
say okay well that's good um you know
but it just kind of brought me down to
earth uh starting in the early 2000s I
began to get much more involved with the
the medical side of things the medical
school had their own IT department and
they set up their own information
security office starting around 2000 in
the y2k days in in preparation for HIPAA
privacy in 2003 and then HIPAA Security
in 2005 now on main campus we were
involved with that and in 2005 also both
sides of campus both IT organizations
were merged and I took over the medical
schools information security office at
that time but even more than that
increasingly a lot of what we've been
doing it does not necessarily always
involve security but it often involves
compliance so a lot of our function has
really been switched over i'd say fifty
percent is now I T compliance an IT
compliance is not always necessarily
security security is there primarily in
support of privacy confidentiality but
also in support of integrity and
availability which are in many cases are
just as important for clinical care you
know that you have integrity of data and
that you have it available to people
that use it when people think of
security they primarily think of it as
securing the data so that it has privacy
and confidentiality now we've come to
realize that you know there are things
which are in the laws and which are in
compliance which are there to preserve
privacy and confidentiality and then
there are some things in there which may
or may not actually provide that in
addition we have
to look at the trade-offs between
patient care and what is needed in
research and patient care and other
things versus what is in regulations
legislation and other parts of
compliance there's great usefulness that
can be done by people in the clinical
and research space you know versus what
sometimes the compliance regulations or
the security standards especially if you
deal with federal agencies which have
increasingly been putting more and more
burdens on us in terms of standards that
we have to follow they've been giving us
data use agreements they've been putting
things into research grants and
contracts so we have to look at what the
risks are and the trade-offs and the
trade-offs can be great in terms of what
you know clinicians and other people can
provide and when we look at the risk we
have to look at what a real risks what
are the threats and you know what are
just those things which are legal
compliance now there are real risks real
threats and I should tell you that every
day we do see them they're much less
today at the medical school since what
we did in the fall then they have been
when I first came into this position
there were computers that were
compromised every day including at the
med school including in clinical
departments and clinics and even after
HIPAA went into effect there would still
be on the order of several week
computers in doctors offices and clinics
which were compromised that number has
come down drastically and since the fall
of 2010 that number has come down quite
a bit so some of the things that we put
in may have seemed York odeon but they
brought that down and that's a good
thing because every time we have a
security incident including just
somebody getting their computer infected
with a virus that's a potential breach
that we have to notify on and that means
that we have to go out and do an
investigation we have to go out and do a
risk analysis and report back to the
HIPAA privacy office the general counsel
and say we do not believe that there was
a disclosure of eph eye on this incident
and in many of those cases there is eph
I it's on the drive and depending on the
organization some organizations place
their burden of proof differently they
say if there was a you know piece of
malicious software if there if there was
an intrusion a computer virus or there
are other classifications and taxonomy
have much to software including worms
and back doors and such
they would often take the burden of
proof to be okay well we can't tell
whether or not there was a disclosure we
may have to notify we may have to
declare a breach from a potential breach
and notify typically we have not done
that we have been able to rule those out
that every one of those thinks is a huge
event and a huge nightmare and concern
for general counsel that they might have
to notify potentially thousands of
people so it's good that we've brought
that down to now where we only see an
incident once a week or sometimes once
every several weeks but still they can
be you know potentially a big problem so
we've changed our name from information
security to security assurance and
compliance we still do see hacking we
still do see intrusions and compromises
and you know in 2010 we took a number of
steps that's continuing today and I'll
talk a little bit about that we also
revised policies in the HIPAA era what
do you think that our major cause of
having large data breaches and
notifications has been here at you it's
not generally hacking it's not generally
intrusions and compromises exactly lost
stolen computers which is really low
tech you know somebody leaves their
laptop somewhere or somebody you know
breaks in and steals their laptop often
from people who get into including
secure clinical areas but they managed
to get in there and sometimes hide until
after hours then route through offices
and take laptops so that's the biggest
problem what do you think is the biggest
potential problem when you look at
electronics you know online forms of
information and it's not really people
getting into servers and getting data
it's generally misdirection of email
email containing Eph I which is sent to
the wrong people very similar to faxes
you know there are a number of
misdirected faxes that that take place
so that's the biggest one in terms of
the frequency although the numbers there
are fairly low you know generally you
see just a few patients or one patient's
name as opposed to spreadsheets or
databases filled with Eph I'm so I'm not
going to go back into the whole history
and saga of HIPAA and hitech just that
in 2003 we implemented privacy here at
Yale and primarily that was done through
training there were some forms there was
policies posted and it was primarily
voluntary compliance in 2005 we did the
same thing for security and along with
that came standards now there were
incremental standards after 2005 until
we made some significant changes in 2010
some of those were driven by external
agencies the VA for example referring to
the last walk was a prime mover and the
VA required us to implement a business
certification for some areas covered by
federal grants and contracts and we did
that we brought in a third party which
came in and did the certification
accreditation they also in 2008 9
required VA data to be secured in
researchers working with VA data to
follow their security standards in many
cases which involved encrypting their
hard drives and taking several other
steps we brought in a security product
at that time PGP whole disk encryption
installed it on Yale researchers who
dealt with the VA at that time later on
that was then extended to other parties
at Yale after the economic downfall of
2008 the US Congress was looking around
to fund many projects and one of them
that they funded was electronic medical
records EHRs in 2009 they funded a bill
called ARRA american reinvestment
Recovery Act which led to HIPAA the
HITECH Act and as part of funding the
elect
chronic health record throughout the
industry and providing subsidies and
incentives for that they also because of
the worry of people of having their
medical information put online
strengthened HIPAA in many cases they
made it much stronger so in 2009 we
looked at high tech and what it would
actually require what it encouraged
etcetera and we made some proposed
policy changes as well as some technical
measures and that went and socialized
throughout the university especially in
those HIPAA covered components in 2009
in early in 2010 we began to circulate
proposed policies into the early summer
of 2010 on august seventeenth of 2010
although a number of groups had been
talking about adopting the new policies
and hi-tech was already in effect at
that point there was a Semel event which
I'm not going to go into here but that
event caused a lightning strike across
the medical school and the HIPAA covered
components sort of the second cultural
revolution at Yale we had had HIPAA and
that had permeated throughout the
organization but on august seventeenth
hi-tech really went across and
university came up with several million
dollars to go out across the HIPAA
covered components in the rest of the
medical school and some other components
and we went out we hired teams we hired
them over 30 people to come in on a
temporary basis and sweep across the
medical schools at first it was sort of
driven and pulled by business managers
and then teams were just sent out to
different departments to go out and
address and remediate machines and we
took a step of technical measures on
those machines you know which in some
cases was a real culture shock but it
has had an effect to really reduce the
number of intrusions and compromises
that we've had now I brought us a lot
closer to the yhh environment yhh has
not had a completely you know security
event free environment either they've
had lost stolen laptops and I should
tell you we also have lost stolen
desktops at you yelled us in some cases
have a problem with physical security so
we've had incidents for example the time
that
any Lee the police were investigating
that at the amistad building over in
another building a person had taken 15
desktops out of a building at Yale
Medical School and loaded them into cars
and some of those about half of those
were actually yhh computers as opposed
to Yale computers so we've worked with y
NH h increasingly to synchronize our
policies because we have a fluid
community that works in both
institutions we've done some crosswalks
between our policies and procedures as
well as our training so that they can be
substituted for each other and there's
some major changes coming along which
are going to tie us more tightly and
bind us together one of those is that
we're going to share an electronic
medical record through the epic system a
lot of work has been going on to secure
that system in the planning stages
there's also going to be a major
clinical trials management system called
encore which will also be managed by
Yale and he'll no hidden hospital and
most of those will actually be hosted at
yale-new Haven Hospital system we work
closely with both ym HHS and the VA as
well as some other organizations and we
participate in the aamc I was on an AMC
group which worked on creating a
document submitting it to the VA and
other federal agencies trying to get
them to relax their rules for security
it at least for research purposes if not
for clinical law contracts and that went
pretty far but before that the VA pretty
much had a very strict FISMA oriented
almost a DoD standard for their medical
information I'm glad to hear that a lot
of that's being relaxed and what we
recommended that was that they should
instead look at using HIPAA as the
standard and bring those things to the
level of HIPAA compliance so I just want
to point out that Yale does have
policies on all different types of
electronic media however it often
doesn't have them specifically on
different classes and we'll go into what
those are so oftentimes we're asked
whether or not it's allowable to do a
certain thing using eph I or to
communicate with patients etc and well
we don't have very specific policies we
have to extrapolate as well as sort of
review the technology and see what type
of controls that has in there for
security for example encryption and
other network security controls we have
policies for example on email which is
you know one of the few that we
specifically point out and sometimes we
extrapolate that but we have policies on
data retention we do have policies on
encryption standards and I should note
that at least in the past we didn't
always have a high degree of compliance
with this people often didn't use
encryption or they use their own
encryption which may or may not have met
the standard in which was not specified
there's also rules for dated disposal
and destruction in addition to how long
you can keep it as well as who can
access it who can you provide data to
now federal agencies where you obtain
data from other groups they will often
have their own you know restrictions and
usually these are spelled out in
documents called DA's data usage
agreements as well as other types of
agreements such as mo use we call them
boz and moves like sheep and cows as
well as business associates agreements
now in most cases you can transmit
information with patients as long as you
have consent and we have consent forms
here at Yale that are used for both
clinical treatment and communicating
with patients as well as for research
one of the big areas at Yale where
people have used for communicating has
also been with portals that was not
successful with ymg as much as it was at
yale-new Haven Hospital where they've
had a very successful patient portal the
only Haven Hospital uses a system for
communicating with patients as well as
community doctors called zix mail we've
looked into all kinds of secure
messaging and you know I just want to
say that right now there are multiple
standards for encrypted email there's
two you know main ones s/mime and PGP
that are not in wide use on the internet
and many minor standards I don't know if
you've ever used a site called hushmail
where you can send secured mail with
other people
note that we do have policies on email
and we actually have a matrix which goes
into who's allowed to send email to whom
under what conditions not all
institutions do this some of them have a
strict no mail policy some of them have
a much simpler one we have become much
more fine-grained into exactly under
what conditions you can do that we don't
have specific policies for IM for web
chat SMS skype we're now as of the new
version allowing it and as of yesterday
you'll see that microsoft's is actually
bought skype and they're going to bring
a new change to it it has had security
problems in the past vulnerabilities it
has a peer-to-peer mode in it and
there's lots of web you know and other
types of video and audio conferencing
services out there such as WebEx and
Adobe Connect which people have used and
have wanted to use here at Yale this is
a whole new class of communication with
people and there are people who wanted
to use this to recruit research subjects
as well as communicate with others and
people have been asking us about these
sites all the time I should just point
out you know that there are risks
associated with these so we had a group
at Yale which wanted to bring in people
who were you know Muslim children at one
point to talk with them and assure them
and we looked at a lot of the threats
that were out there and worked on
dealing with them one thing is that
there's actually a federal regulation
called Coppa copp a which says that you
have students who are 13 or under if to
obtain their parents permission for them
to you know participate in these
websites now that doesn't actually apply
to nonprofits such as Yale some of the
problems and the threats that we've seen
in the past these are often times in the
K through 12 group are harassment and
bullying which does take place on some
social networks intrusion and hijacking
which I spoke of before spamming and
fishing are becoming a much greater
problem on Facebook and other places and
I anticipate that we'll see a good bit
of spam on Facebook and others and
identity theft which brings me to the
next slide
so we do see identity theft we have had
cases here at Yale involving yield
people primarily we see it involved in
financial identity theft or people that
are using it for harassment we have not
seen a great deal of medical identity
theft but it's out there we've also seen
a good bit of reputational risk and this
brings in other risks where if people do
participate as healthcare consumers you
know with different types of social
media including these new social media
that we saw before they can end up you
know doing things in their youth with
indiscretions that later could follow
them if they show examples of alcohol
and drug abuse if they talk about
diseases or medical treatments or mental
or physical conditions you know
sometimes that information stays around
on these sites forever so there are
different types of reputational risk
which could involve you know
pre-existing conditions and getting
insurance or future employment
opportunities